[music]
That's no symphony.
It's the sound ofa supernova remnant called CassiopeiaA.
A team of scientists and musicians has
created musical versions of telescope images
In these "sonifications", brighter objects translateto louder notes
Objects near the top of the imagetranslate to higher pitches.
And different kindsof light are played on different instruments.
Take this image of the center of the milky way.
We've got the violin on an optical light solo,
the xylophone on an x-ray light solo,
and thepiano on an infrared light solo.
All together the harmony reveals glowing clouds of gas and dust...
scattered with stars.
So far scientists have cuttracks of some iconic telescope images.
Buteach composition sounds a little different.
What you're hearing now are thePillars of Creation in the Eagle Nebula.
Those whistles indicate x-rays from stars,
andthat low drone is one of the three pillars,
finger-like plumes of gasand dust where stars are born.
These musical scores and others like them
could make astronomy more accessible for
people with blindness or vision impairments,
offering a new way to tour the cosmos.
[music]